Transcription: Samira Kwache
Relecteur: eric vautier
Une bouffée d’air.
Je peux la respirer à pleins poumons.
L’air de la liberté.
L’air du bonheur.
Une nouvelle ère, une nouvelle saison.
Celle du don de soi.
Celle de l’impact.
Finies les périodes de pleurs.
Finies les heures sombres des railleries.
L’ère est à la passion, à la dévotion.
Libre d’aller où je veux
et de faire ce que j’aime.
Je suis Michelle Gonto-Kouame
et l’État ivoirien me désigne
comme sage-femme.
Mais dans le jeu de la vie,
je suis une battante,
une conquérante,
mieux, une gagnante.
(Applaudissements)
En 2003, j’obtiens mon Baccalauréat,
et tout le monde :
amis, parents et professeurs
sont unanimes pour dire que
je suis promise à un bel avenir.
À l’époque, je veux devenir magistrat.
J’intègre donc la Faculté de droit
de l’Université Catholique
de l’Afrique de l’Ouest.
Et en 2008, après ma maîtrise,
eh bien, je veux réaliser mon rêve.
Je présente donc le concours d'entrée
à l'École de magistrature.
Mais non, les portes
ne s’ouvrent pas pour moi.
Et donc, de 2008 à 2012,
je force, je veux y arriver.
Mais après deux ans, l'âge avançant,
je commence à varier les concours.
Je présente aussi celui de l’ENA,
celui de l’ENS, de l’IPNETP, de l’INFS.
Enfin, presque tous les concours
de la fonction publique
mais sans toucher
aux métiers de la santé.
Pour moi, à l’époque,
c’était hors de question.
Mais je prends de l’âge
et puis, j’ai des besoins.
Et je n’aime pas tendre la main.
Alors, je commence à enchaîner
les petits métiers.
Donc, je vends de l’Atiéké ;
après, je vends de l’Aloko.
Après, je vends des dessous pour femmes.
Et après, je fais même serveuse de bar.
Oui, j’ai été serveuse
dans des bars à Yopougon
et même caissière dans ces mêmes bars ;
je fais un peu de tout
pourvu que j’aie de l’argent.
Mais je sens qu’il y a
quelque chose d’inassouvi en moi.
Et toujours, la petite question
quand on rencontre les amis de fac
ou les amis d'école.
« Qu’est-ce que tu deviens ? »
La question. Et là, tu rases les murs,
ou bien tu changes de sujet rapidement.
Et j’étais dans cet état d’esprit
très frustrée
lorsqu’en début 2013,
je revois un ami de fac, Israël Dubo.
Il me pose la même question
quand on discute :
« Qu’est-ce que tu deviens ?
- Je ne deviens rien.
Je suis à la maison.
- Ce n’est pas possible.
Fais-moi parvenir ton CV. »
Il avait une boîte de webmarketing
et il accepte de me prendre
comme stagiaire.
Donc, je suis social media manager junior.
Je commence dans cette boîte.
Du droit au digital.
Bon, vraiment, le jour et la nuit.
Mais, je suis en bonne voie.
Je suis disposée, j’apprends vite
et très tôt, je tire mon épingle du jeu.
J’apprends le b.a.-ba du métier
et puis, ça va.
Donc, c’est bien.
C’est chic. Tout va bien.
J’ai un travail. J’ai un salaire.
Je peux à nouveau sourire. La vie va bien.
Et puis, un matin... Bim !
Le ciel s’obscurcit sur ma tête.
Le tonnerre gronde de partout,
les éclairs…
Je suis enceinte.
(Soupire)
Et quand j’apprends la nouvelle,
je ne sais pas trop si je dois danser
ou si je dois pleurer
parce que je suis enceinte
sur les décombres
d’une relation amoureuse,
sur les ruines d’une relation amoureuse.
C’était déjà fini.
Donc, ça mourait, quoi !
Et puis, je me suis rendu compte
que j’étais enceinte.
Une grossesse très difficile
qui m’oblige à arrêter le travail
parce que j’ai des douleurs
tout le temps.
Puisque j’ai ce qu’on appelle
un utérus polymyomateux.
Je suis contrainte d’arrêter le travail.
Je me retrouve seule.
Donc, je souffre émotionnellement,
je souffre également physiquement.
Je retombe encore dans la déprime.
Le travail que j’avais eu, qui me
donnait tant de joie, je ne l’ai plus.
Je suis enceinte,
je suis dans le lourd goumin.
Mais dans cette obscurité,
Dieu a envoyé un ange -
oui, je pèse mes mots, un ange -
pour me redonner du courage.
C’était un soir de juin 2013
alors que j’avais été admise
au service gynécologique
du CHR de Divo, aux urgences
pour menaces d’accouchement prématuré.
Les larmes perlaient sur mes joues.
Mon corps était secoué par des sanglots
et une des sages-femmes de service
ce jour-là s’est approchée de moi.
Elle m’a prise par la main,
elle m’a regardée dans les yeux,
elle m’a serrée dans ses bras et
elle m’a dit : « Je sais que c’est dur
mais ça va aller. Tu as la force
pour supporter ça. Prends courage. »
Et elle m’a expliqué pourquoi
je souffrais autant.
Enfin j’avais une réponse à mes questions.
Ça m'a donné de la force.
Je me suis fortifiée et grâce à ça,
j’ai pu mener la grossesse jusqu’à terme.
Et le 27 octobre 2013,
j’ai accouché de mon garçon Samuel.
À partir de cet instant,
ma façon de penser les métiers
de la santé avait complètement changé.
Je me suis dit : « Moi aussi,
je veux être une oreille attentive.
Oui, moi aussi, je veux aider.
Oui, moi aussi, je veux pouvoir donner
le sourire de l’espoir à une femme,
à une jeune fille qui se pose
mille et une questions sur la maternité.
Je veux devenir sage-femme. »
Je présente alors
le concours d’entrée à l’INFAS.
Et là, je suis reçue du premier coup.
Je commence ma formation.
Vous n’ignorez pas,
mes amis me demandent…
Ils voient que je suis à l’INFAS,
mais on se moque de moi.
Et lors d’une réunion de famille,
alors que je conseillais une cousine
de continuer ses études,
on m’a dit : « Pardon !
Ton papier que tu as eu, ce n’est pas
pour finir dans une maternité ? »
On se moque de moi,
mais ça ne me touche pas
parce que je sens dans mon cœur
un appel, une vocation.
Je sais que c’est ma voie que j’ai trouvée
et je me promets de ne pas être
une sage-femme ordinaire.
Je finis après trois ans
et ma formation est soldée
par un diplôme d’État
en sciences infirmières et obstétricales.
Et dès que je sors,
forte de l’expérience que
j’avais acquise dans le digital -
souvenez-vous que
j’ai été social media manager -
j’ouvre une page qui s’appelle
« Case maternelle »,
qui traite de toutes les questions
de santé sexuelle et de la reproduction.
Mon objectif, c’est de briser
les tabous autour de la maternité,
de briser les tabous
autour de la sexualité.
Mon objectif, c’est d’apporter
l’information aux femmes
parce qu’une grossesse,
quand on est informé,
quand on sait ce qu’on vit,
on la vit mieux.
Je suis maman depuis à peine six semaines.
Cette grossesse n'a pas été
plus facile que l'autre.
C’est toujours les mêmes conditions, mais
je l’ai mieux vécue car j’étais informée
et j’ai été accompagnée
par mon époux et ma famille.
Donc, quand on est accompagné et informé,
la maternité change complètement.
Et avec Case maternelle aussi,
mon objectif est de faire la
promotion de la profession de sage-femme
car nous ne sommes pas
toujours bien vues.
Je veux montrer que la sage-femme,
ce n’est pas seulement
celle qui fait : « Poussez, madame ! »
Non. La sage-femme est aussi jeune,
elle est aussi fun, elle sait aussi rire.
Elle sait aussi amuser.
Elle sait écouter.
Elle sait partager son vécu.
Elle sait partager l'information.
C’est ça aussi notre rôle
et pas seulement « Madame, poussez. »
Et j’ai commencé
à le faire avec Case maternelle.
D’autres sages-femmes m’ont rejointe.
Même des personnes
hors du métier de la santé
parce qu’on produit des capsules vidéo,
on fait des campagnes sur le terrain.
J’ai de la chance -
Dieu me fait la grâce d’avoir
des personnes loyales qui m’accompagnent
et qui me comprennent,
qui me soutiennent, qui me portent haut.
Et l'une de ces personnes,
c'est mon époux.
Je l'ai rencontré à l'école.
Il est infirmier et
nous avons fait chemin ensemble.
(Applaudissements)
Voilà, Case maternelle,
ma vie de sage-femme.
C’est ce qui me rend heureuse,
je me sens vivre
quand je donne, quand j’apporte.
Je me sens vivre quand je vais
dans ces écoles parler aux filles.
L’année dernière, la campagne,
c’était « Mon vagin, ma vie ».
Ça choquait un peu mais après, même
les professeurs m’approchaient pour dire :
« Madame, vous avez raison
de donner cette information. »
J’aime aller vers ces femmes
dans les villages, dans les campagnes.
Ma première campagne,
c’était dans mon village.
À près de 700 km d’Abidjan,
à 12 km de la frontière du Libéria.
Là-bas, il n’y a pas de centres de santé.
J’y suis allée,
j’ai discuté avec les matrones.
On a échangé sur leurs pratiques.
Elles m’ont acceptée
et m’appellent « collègue ».
Moi, j'aime bien ça.
C'est chic comme ça.
Case maternelle,
c’est ce qui me fait vraiment vivre.
On me demande parfois : « Comment
tu fais entre ton travail à la maternité
et ce que tu fais pour Case maternelle ? »
Je dis toujours : « Je ne me sens pas
en train de travailler.
Je me sens en train de faire
quelque chose que j'aime.
Je veux donner à la vie
ce qu’elle m’a donnée
mais aussi ce qu’elle
n’a pas pu me donner.
Les informations que je n’ai pas eues,
je veux que d’autres femmes les aient. »
Case maternelle,
c’est plus de 135 000 abonnés aujourd’hui.
Dix pays qui nous suivent.
50 messages en moyenne par jour.
Parfois, c'est difficile à gérer.
Plus de 500 000 personnes qui
ont été impactées, 30 émissions tournées.
Ce sont des capsules que j’ai appelées :
« Allô La Sage » qui traite d’un thème
que nous diffusons chaque semaine.
Et plus de 5000 kilomètres parcourus.
Nous ne restons pas que dans le digital.
Il y a des femmes qui n’ont pas Internet
et qui ont aussi besoin d’être informées.
Les épreuves, les frustrations que
nous vivons doivent être le carburant
qui vont nous pousser
plus loin, plus haut.
Le plus important,
(Applaudissements)
c’est de savoir tirer les conséquences,
de savoir tirer les bonnes leçons,
en s’appuyant sur des valeurs
comme l’intégrité,
des valeurs comme l’honnêteté,
refuser la compromission.
Quand j’ai commencé,
on m’a dit un jour :
« Toi, tu ne peux rien créer, tu ne peux
rien changer. Tu es venue trouver. »
Je n'ai pas prétention à changer le monde.
Je n’ai pas prétention à changer
toutes les sages-femmes
mais j’ai prétention à faire mieux,
du mieux que je peux avec le peu que j’ai.
C’est vrai que
mes conditions de travail parfois…
Mais non, je ne m’apitoie pas sur ça.
Je veux regarder plus l’intérêt
des femmes que j’ai en face de moi.
Apprenons à donner, à nous donnet
nous-mêmes, à nous surpasser
sans forcément regarder à notre intérêt.
Grâce à Case maternelle, à ce travail
que j’ai fait bénévolement
et qui m’a coûtée tant physiquement,
matériellement que financièrement,
aujourd’hui,
j’ai pu être appelée par presque
toutes les chaînes de télévision de
Côte d’Ivoire et même à l’international.
J’étais enceinte de deux mois de
mon dernier garçon quand j’ai été à Lomé
pour tourner avec TV5 pour
« Les maternelles d’Afrique ».
Je suis en train de signer
avec des sociétés
qui veulent travailler avec
Case maternelle pour aller plus loin.
Alors qu’à l’origine,
je voulais juste donner.
Donner, c'est l'essence de la vie.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)